[Music]
hey everyone we just got to play two
hours of Forza horizon and you know this
is looking like the biggest expansion to
date that the series has ever seen so
David you've been following the series
for a while so tell me um is there
certain things about this game that
you're actually really looking forward
to yeah absolutely I started Forza
probably with the first game that came
out and since then there's been many
significant changes and probably Forza
horizon fours biggest change would have
to be its revamped season system that
they're utilizing and its brand new
location in England the season system is
actually quite more than just anything
aesthetic it's gonna be affecting the
way that you race the way that you drift
and quite frankly a lot of the tune ups
that you might be interested in doing
into your car you're gonna have to
factor in that in any of these races at
any point you might have to be driving
across multiple versions of different
terrain you're gonna go off-road a lot
so there's a lot of like driving through
trees and like you know dense forests
and you know with the upcoming seasons
they're actually gonna change the
terrain a lot and uh we actually got to
see a bit of that during this opening a
race here which was a really great way
to you know get people into you know the
action and you know so the pacing of
this game each season will not only have
its own unique driving missions but also
each season will affect sort of the
terrain and sort of the driving style
you'll have to employ so obviously like
when you're driving a winter you're
gonna have to be more careful with your
turns because things are gonna get
really wet and may drift out if you're
gonna drift out and uh you know the same
thing happens in the autumn as well
because that's when the rain comes in
they actually said there's still gonna
be rain in summer too because that's
just classic angling for you that horse
in fact the one thing that's really cool
about Forza in its intros is how it sort
of immerses you it starts out with this
very cinematic looking cutscene and then
just band you're right in the middle of
flying across these tracks in a hypercar
and Forza horizon 4 did a very good job
of showcasing how these seasons are
gonna be transitioning
at one point you start out very on a
very standard track with a very nice
sports car and then all of a sudden you
are actually flying and driving across
ice in a very off-road truck and so
horses really excited it seems to just
kind of Bend the experience of your
standard open-world racing game you
almost have this sort of encouragement
to go off-road to veer into fences to
cause mayhem and destruction all while
trying to get to your waypoint location
in a way that's very fun I think a lot
of that has to do with the fact that
they move the setting to the United
Kingdom this is more of a fictionalized
a heavily fictionalized version of like
Edinburg and like any other the English
countryside so we're seeing a lot of
like sort of rustic like towns but also
a lot of dense forests absolutely and in
fact you even see a new feature that
Forza horizon 4 is introducing compared
to its predecessors where you now have
these bases it's a great way to show off
the new map and the new countryside that
they have and it's a great way to show
off the new features where you were able
to go to these bases kind of make them
your own and it looks very very accurate
it looks really cool you know you get to
turn it into your own home and you have
all these customization options where
you can create different types of styles
for your character if your drive ATAR
you can really kind of embellish your
personality in it there's something
that's really neat there there's
actually one you know outfit that's
basically like a disco chicken outfit
and it is very expensive and you know
there was no way I could have afforded
that you know right from the beginning
right they want you to earn that by sure
doing all the missions you can so I was
really impressed with you know the
amount of detail like you know within
each car but also just in how you didn't
sort of customize your own character you
know who will have a greater impact on
the world by also you know sort of
making their presence known but within
the online world itself they actually
did a lot to sort of a
expand upon like the drive ATAR aspect
because obviously the focus here is the
cars and you know it's you know the the
world itself is like you know a place
where there are more cars than people
like existing but which makes sense
because this is a driving game but
having the base and like you know having
more customization options like for your
character goes a really long way to you
know getting yourself like a sense of
place in the world and that goes into
like the online aspect which they
greatly expanded upon in this version of
the game as well oh yeah I mean these
these servers are massive you know you
can have I believe over 70 people in one
instance at a time I mean that is just
incredible Corsa has really taken that
to heart and really expanded upon it in
the new game we were able to interact
with different people out in the world
when you're online you're able to
challenge them to one-on-one races
you're able to start new events where
people can join you and it's just a
really it's a really immersive and great
way to be able to play with other people
online at your own discretion and of
course you know if you want to get away
from the online you can always switch on
the option for the solo mode absolutely
so you know it's there if you want it
but you're not exactly forced into it
because the developers also stated that
they wanted to sort of make sure that
people weren't getting grieved by you
know others online so the constantly
getting hassled will chase them you know
throughout the country sites and that's
a great step that the developers taken
as well really creating Forza and of
this type of game where all types of
gamers can really enjoy this racing
simulator and again this is a big
expansion especially considering from
the last game there's a 450 cars this
time around yeah it's a lot and each car
has its own sort of specific like
customization options to them obviously
the you know the gear heads will know
like you know exactly what you'll want
to change oh yeah absolutely I mean and
then that was a thing that force has
always been giving credit to is its
dedication to having these cars have
just a a you know in a none
lievable amount of customizable options
where you can change things as simple as
the tire pressure to the the weight of
the car itself to the stock to the
engine I mean and at the same time
though which again is a testament to
forces willingness to embrace all type
of gamers there's also an auto upgrade
option available so for those who might
not necessarily know what is the best
option for them there is that
availability for them to just upgrade
their cars whichever card that they like
to be able to still stay competitive
although of course those who know what
they are doing are going to have that
sort of extra competitive edge when they
are racing online and of course there's
also a really dense soundtrack as well
yes I heard Kendrick Lamar on the sound
tractor and one of my off-road racing
like missions and you know that actually
helped me get into the mood like you
know I'm actually helped finish that
race and the soundtrack is always
important for like you know a sort of
fast pace like you know over-the-top
racing game like this right and and you
know just going back to forces I would
consider their sense of humor they have
such a variety of different sort of
radio channels that you can dial into
you have your typical you know heart
thumping techno and your trance and all
that sort of stuff or your heavy rock
but they also have at least they did in
one of the older games and I hope they
have it again here they had like a
classical radio station so if you can
just really back oh it is that's great
because now if you can just imagine
yourself flying across hills and doing
these you know crazy aerial stunts in
the Bugatti while listening to Beethoven
it's just it's great yeah
yeah and it's so cool because you end up
having this sort of proof that Forza is
not just a game where you are going to
be going from track to track racing you
do have this option to not just free
roam but actually take part in
objectives and side quests that have you
do these sort of ridiculous things I
mean launching yourself off a hill and
having these you know jets flying over
you that's not something you're going to
find very often in other racing games in
addition to you know sort of the
specific missions that the developer is
gonna put in there's also gonna be like
daily missions and weekly missions that
you'll have to take part in to you know
get more rewards but also maybe access
to certain cars and like certain
customization options for your drive
ATAR it does seem to be in your benefit
to to open up a variety of different
cars just so you can be able to drive
through this terrain as efficiently as
possible so you're not you know drifting
in your Lamborghini and yeah we're in a
couple of feet of snow you don't need to
drive your Ferrari in the snow just a
bad idea for those of you who also have
the Xbox one game pass all of Xbox one's
first party titles are available for
game Pass owners and due to its xbox
play anywhere system as well if you have
bought the game or pre-ordered the game
on one platform you will also be able to
get it on the corresponding platform as
well but yeah ports horizon is looking
fantastic it's gonna be out October 2nd
on Xbox one and PC and players on both
platforms will be able to you know play
together during cross play so thanks for
joining me David absolutely my pleasure
thanks for watching
you ready ready let's do this